good morning Hank it's Wednesday it's
pizza mess we've just come from the Save
the Children gala I met Jennifer Garner
that was weird
and I but she seemed cool I stood nearby
Olivia Wilde
it could be a gala or a gala do you want
to answer some questions yes so just
sent John Green what is your opinion on
lamps I am opposed to them I love lamp
debate over the best kind of chocolate
white milk or dark I don't know if this
is going to be a debate but I actually
have a very strong opinion so let's just
do this one two three one two three
dark oh thank God because we were about
to not be brothers anymore will there
ever be dear Hank and John merch that's
what the world is missing is dear Hank
and John merch you know what gotta merch
we do have pizza John Murtagh yeah only
for a couple more days at dftba.com
pizza miss merch
it's like suits but mostly t-shirts
actually you know what I was angling to
do but the whole challah he likes to
keep me close to his heart
John yeah do your best impression of
your favorite dinosaur we don't know
what dinosaur sound like it's true maybe
nobody I'm glad you made it at least you
made a noise that was a Diplodocus my
favorite dinosaur
oh but we don't know if that's what they
sound like we don't know we have no way
of knowing ah
we have no way of them maybe they just
were like sound like humans they're just
like all right Rob Rob Rob Rob Rob I bet
dog from that that thing on tumblr pop
pop pop pop pop da Prez you gotta took
away my tumblr password so I don't know
what's happening on tumblr anymore I'm
not that bad
sounds funny it's pretty fun I did you
take away my tumblr Benson there's so
many lovely things happening I gotta pop
Nicole's question is what are your
holiday traditions say what we're
thankful for
our mom always puts tremendous pressure
on
sooo pressure to come up with like a new
thing that we're thankful for to
advicing like I'm thankful for my kids
mom will always say no no no no you said
that in 2011 I got to think of something
new that I'm thankful for and I'm 38 you
know yeah
thirty years of having to be grateful
yeah you gotta you know I take
individual foods this year I'm thankful
for green pea cuz I'm so grateful for
cranberries where would we be without
them as a species yeah roughly exactly
the same place but where would
cranberries be they would be dead like
40% of species which we've eliminated in
the last 500 years low team actually no
I was not an appropriate high five yeah
well I mean 99.9% of species that have
existed no longer exist right but
usually not so rapidly we've eliminated
more in the last 400 years than than in
the previous million yeah yeah we're
roughly on par with an asteroid we are
killing it Oh
literally Hank can you please describe
the meaning of life from the perspective
of a chicken hey how did you and John
meet your wives I met my wife she lived
across a desert continent alway an ocean
from my from my dorm room all right room
service is here we have to go Hank yeah
thank you for being awesome I like your
tie by the way
welcome I got it a banana republic dftba
I will see you right now and also
tomorrow